we now share much - my favorite game of
all time
Jude Aras simulator apparently this game
is only 5% done whoa I'm in here now I
can what you see why I say it's my
favorite game because I can change my
underwear little dirty I'm going for the
striped blinds cos the stripes shows up
the girls up there girls
but best game i have ever played man
there's a senpai shrine this game is I
can't this is the toothbrush that I
stole from senpai so brushing my teeth
with this is a wonderful feeling this is
a bandage that sent bite through away
somewhere miss delicious blood is still
on it this is the Apple I'd like to buy
the licking in the teeth market so much
fun how to stay I will not run house how
fresh is this Apple oh my god I'm so
excited for this [ __ ] game basement
can I keep people captain oh I love this
I [ __ ] love this everything making my
way downtown
yes yeah
this is why play this game
okay we're now I kind of to go attack on
time in mode but we are however going to
have this toaster in our mouth but
better bap bap bap better PO skippity
Scoob it is skew which one is my some
pie others there's male students now as
well are you Michael chat I can't see
cuz the [ __ ] toaster is in my face
deaf Miko Miko Chan I love you big fan
nice titties
oh hello oh it's that senpai I'm so weak
in front of senpai let's get some weird
pictures here behind the trees yep a two
week to week oh oh no I weirded out
senpai no I don't understand why I why
I'm so weird ah she's trying to escape
make a Chan right in the face oh oh what
are they learning the back no zip iPad
notice me note it notice them senpai I
grew them just for you senpai better
take a picture with a s the greatest ass
look at that yes look at that ass oh my
god
scary so [ __ ] up look at the titties
they're making it hard to drag bra
senpai [ __ ] looked at senpai now I look
at your panties damn it I knew I should
have where Dwight Penny's so laughing
makes me sane again that's creepy this
[ __ ] hell what a mournful morning
dead people there I can send the picture
to him
with the [ __ ] that I just send it to
[ __ ] love brooms [ __ ] love brooms
[ __ ] up with your big [ __ ] love
brooms [ __ ] love boobs which is love
side broom when I bro my sweet mouth
[ __ ] it's not sweet my [ __ ] last
week my [ __ ] off the flow [ __ ] oh I
want to make my boobs cronut reset the
entire game Oh God [ __ ]
okay let's seriously try and kill every
one of them you have some more time now
to murder [ __ ] you got [ __ ] surd
okay this is excellent I could pick them
off while they don't see it all right we
did it and you go wait I'm so lucky
there's a furnace place here it really
it really comes to great use let's see
okay last one Jesus Christ and you go
ahead I did it ha ha all right we did it
it took me a [ __ ] hour Jesus Christ
what is my deadline what am I supposed
to do on Friday [ __ ] hell which pen
jeez are we gonna wear today I feel I
feel like the spandex
I love spandex it's only some pie left
yes me and seminaries man [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] is God like dough in the firmness
of a [ __ ] [ __ ] is gonna go inside the
furnace oh my god somebody's here ah
let's get a good picture of his [ __ ]
face you wanna [ __ ] sit on that
[ __ ] face do you want me to identify
two student please let and get me a
clear shot of face I'm trying but it's
simple I press it looks like the game
ends there but we'll keep going when the
game updates thank you so much for
watching I had a lot of fun playing
leave a like if you want more of this
your diary simulator and I'll see you
the next one as always press stay
awesome step by step by smart senpai I
love you I love you senpai oh look it's
maker maker oh damn them titties what a
great time in school